it's now 1 15. so we can give you the
answers of a snap overnight uh yougov
poll of conservative members now these
are the people who will decide in the
final two and they reveal
that if penny mordant gets in the final
two
according to this poll she will become
the next prime minister penny morden who
launched her campaign today who's not
the favorite amongst openly declared
tory mps
is on course to beat every single one of
her rivals in the last two according to
this yougov poll taken overnight since
that close of nominations last night the
eight candidates were all put to around
800 tory members and the results are
very stark
they put
they put
penny mordent number one of the list of
choices they put um kenny badenock
number two so if i just go through some
of the numbers here
uh
what you have is um uh amongst uh
everyone was asked who their first
choice uh would be uh penny morden came
out first with 27 percent of the vote
kemi beijing came second with 15 percent
of the vote uh and mr sunak and mistrust
uh rishi soon and liz trust tied on
third place in 13 of the votes so just
pause for a moment there liz cross and
rishi sunak running the two most high
high profile campaigns in this poll
they're coming third after that tom
toucan had on eight percent so ella
braverman on five percent jeremy hunt on
four percent and nadim zahawi on one
percent six percent saying none of the
above uh and uh eight percent say they
don't know that's quite a low number but
then of course the way that this contest
works is next week two names will be
selected by mps to go through to the
tory membership which we think is around
160 000 uh people and so you have put
different sets of names to their panel
to uh to the polls uh two tory members
to say who would you win and the results
are incredibly stark penny morden beats
rishi sunak 67 to 28 that's a landslide
penny morden beats liz truss by 55 to 37
still an incredible margin um and then
she beat uh kemi badanok by 59
to 30
now in the event the mps as it were
conspired decide that penny morden
shouldn't make the final two for it is
their choice then liz truss would beat
rishi sunak 67
to 28 so again another very
comprehensive margin so that's the
result of a snap overnight poll of 879
touring members two massive headlines if
penny mordant gets to the final two
she's on course to be prime minister and
a very bad poll for rishi sunak and this
matters doesn't it because i guess uh
mps will be looking at these numbers
like you and i are and trying to work
out tactically where they should put
their vote yeah there are two
motivations when mps uh come to decide
who they're back for the next
conservative party leader and prime
minister the first is who's going to get
them re-elected in their seat
and the second is who's going to win and
could give them a job and these kind of
this kind of bit of data is incredibly
important at this point because there's
been a momentum publicly behind rishi
sunak he's got all those wits working
for him from mark harper to gavin
williamson and we believe julian smith
and there have been lots of big names
coming out for him but if suddenly it
doesn't look like he'd win with mps or
he didn't or he doesn't in this poll
as is the case look like he'd win with
the membership does that momentum
continue i'm not sure it's that bad for
liz trust she's still in a strong
position if penny morden doesn't make it
but wow penny borden who only launched
her campaign this morning and he did one
interview on a radio station last night
we've only really had a video otherwise
from her wasn't a top flight cabinet
member at the point of which she
launched her campaign
as backed by figures like andrea ledson
is running helping to run her campaign
appears to have pole vaulted into first
place in this competition very big
moment here we are at the height of
voting